[Music]
all right what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we are featuring harpie try
what's going on how are you thanks for
coming out of the show Thank You Man
appreciate it glad we're able to connect
hekia and especially because the
technology that you're building with
ordering is super important for our
world and you came and came and tell
like pass pass pass pass me one of those
these are so interesting so that what we
have here is ordering and ordering is
now helping you measure your sleep it's
helping you measure your heart rate your
heart rate variability and it's doing
this beautifully on an app for you I
mean you and making it really relatable
you can't even tell that you're wearing
this yeah it's uh you know it's making
it visible and visible right and then
also making the invisible visible
there's all these things happening in
your body and we're trying to show
people sort of you know how they can
learn about how those things work and
you know understand and make better
lifestyle choices to improve their lives
yeah see this okay so before we unpack
all the lifestyle choices and everything
and how you guys are helping them
helping people how about we talk about
the to the team this team is in Finland
and Finland
yes yeah then that's a place of quite a
bit of interesting circadian rhythm a
ton impact yeah yeah I think it's pretty
interesting brought up so when you look
at Finland you know if any of you guys
go it's dark half the year and really
right half the year and because of that
obviously you know they've been doing
research on circadian rhythm obviously
you know people are faced with sort of
stalker you know climate changes you
know night and light and so because of
that they've been researching it almost
longer than anyone so a lot of good
sleep technologies come out of the
Nordics especially Finland mm-hmm and
that's like six months like the summer
months there's not much night time
correct and the winter months there's
not much day time yeah yeah that's right
so I'll be there next week and I mean
it'll probably be light until you know 1
a.m. 2 a.m. and it'll get dusk for a
little bit and then come you know 4 a.m.
5 a.m. it's bright and sunny again now
and then the winter it's the exact
opposite so yeah yeah that's the summer
is awesome it's also hard to go to bed
because you're like sowing it because
it's like you know it's 10 o'clock and
it's bright outside and you're with your
friends finishing up dinner or drink and
like oh this is awesome it's just like
late summer nights but yeah that you
know that winter is exactly opposite so
it's a little bit more depressing so all
this research has been done in the
Nordics on sleep you know what have been
some of the things that have been
learned ya know it's a really good
question I think a bunch is sort of two
main topics how much sleep matters sort
of you know sleeping this optimal time
where your body recovers where your mind
recovers you know I like to think about
it as sleeps a foundation of your body
in your mind you know and we'll go
through some stuff I think you had Matt
Walker's book out yeah yeah earlier so
you know I think he does it the best but
I don't know you know and I think the
the other area too is just for this
light exposure so going to bed is one
thing but then getting that light
exposure as well early in the morning to
get your circadian you know your
circadian clock aligned and getting all
the right hormones you know actually
it's called sort of your wake drive
versus or sleep pressure we don't need
to get into too much of that now but
just starting your day off right and if
you think about us in San Francisco you
know my day today woke up pretty early
did a bunch of calls inside jumped in an
uber to come meet you here to tape this
who didn't really get much sunlight
that's not how we were designed
so artificial light you know blue light
at night or just fluorescent lights
during the day not getting sunlight you
know is another big issue in today's
society yeah so I think you've seen a
lot of this like work manifests itself
you know circadian biology there was a
Nobel Prize just last year about it so
it's starting to gain you know gain a
lot more attention so it's about how
much sleep we get and how much light we
get sunlight yeah so the Nordics have
been studying this and then the Nordics
are now like let's make something to
help us better understand what exactly
is going on with these biometrics we
always we always talk about the
importance of figuring out how to
measure the data that we leave behind
how to make it applicable to our lives
totally and so that's kind of what
you're doing with sleep hari hari
variability yep so ok so now this is
this is now I mean I remember seeing
your first version and your first
version was a lot larger yeah I mean you
were able to really thin this down quite
a bit and don't know Ron it's got a
bunch of images and we're let's throw
one of those up into the stream and
you'll see here like that's a really
good close-up of the ring yeah and this
is this is puny I mean it's it's like
it's puny in co-signs comparison yeah
yeah no I mean look it's we're trying to
get it down to something people would
want to wear every day I think Kara
Swisher in one of her podcast a couple
years ago you know from recode she
talked about how she calls them on
wearables like these some of the things
are so distracting or so bulky or they
take away from sort of your sense of
fashion right something being personal
exactly that we're trying to make you
know these in different colors so that
they're sort of you know not noticeable
they just blend in with your life you
know there's no lights no digital lights
on it I was done for a conscious effort
yeah we wanted to you know be part of
your life right not have your life
revolve around it not just another thing
to keep checking yep
and I love this rose gold one in terms
of color yeah I think that one looks
great this matte black one looks amazing
silver looks amazing as well now like
you said you don't want it to be -
there's the collection we got a we got a
discount code as well for every one link
in the bio definitely go check out or a
ring now we like here's and here's so
here's something that you just mentioned
you don't want it to be you know to take
away too much from your lifestyle like
be too bulky you guys have gotten the
technology down to a very small amount
so let's you know we'll unpack the
technology as well for you right now so
as we as we look at you know what are
these three as three lumps down here yep
yeah yeah there's little lumps not
there's LOM Sutherlands so there's three
of them there's two on the outsides and
one in the middle so the two on the
outsides are infrared LEDs so light
emitting diodes and then the center
one's actually a detector and for a
detector and so we're shining light
which shows infrared so it's not green
it doesn't bother you while you sleep
you know it's invisible if anything
there's been some you know scientific
literature about infrared being healing
to the body but yeah we use infrared
light we're shining that light 250 times
a second that's a lot of it's a lot of
yeah and the people are doing way less
than that yeah I would say the lowest
we've seen out there in the market has
been as low as like two times three
times a second I think some of you know
some of the other devices well during
work at mode or about you know twenty to
forty Hertz or forty times a second and
yeah we're sampling at you know 250
Hertz so that allows us to get actually
a much more accurate picture of your
heart rate and your heart rate
variability which a lot of people are
using a measure of stress which is
pretty interesting and we also use this
information for sleep staging as well
yep okay so then the two infrared yep
are shining and then you're sensing from
this infrared sensor yeah most wearables
are sort of if you want to think about
like a radar radar
gun you know you're shining something
but then that has to bounce back so most
radar guns have both parts they have
like it you know an emitter and a
detector so our detectors just in the
middle and we have two you know two
different when you're using infrared so
that way it's invisible to the eye so
you can't be disturbed by it during
sleep yep definitely yeah and there's
some nice characteristics about infrared
but yeah that's definitely one of them
we liked what are some of the other ones
that are good I mean some of the other
ones you know I think every wavelength
if you get into the optics side you know
they have their benefits and negatives
so infrared tends to be better for some
of the you know I would say use cases
that we're using for heart rate that's
about all I can say so I think for our
use case for especially sleep detection
HR and HRV and Freud tends to be pretty
good
so now let's let's talk about yeah good
you all there's a couple other sensors
in there you can't see them all so we
have two different thermistor or
temperature sensors thermistor they're
misters I don't know
must have been a dude who came up with
that name so there's you know two
thermistors in there are temperature
sensors you know we use that as well you
know one of the things we talked about
or you'll see when you use the ring if
you're if you're getting a cold you know
we'll be able to see that body
temperatures start to increase that we
try to point that out to people so they
can try to do something about it you
know or at least take it easy that day
because most times you'll start to see
you know some of this you won't feel the
symptoms until it's too late so try to
get you some information early there and
then we also have an accelerometer in
there and a gyroscope yes well so that
acts as a pedometer four steps odometer
four steps and we're gonna be doing more
on the activity tracking side in the
future as well what else would an
accelerometer a gyroscope tow you know
most people in the wearable space have
used them just for detecting you know
steps running but then also other
general movements so I heard that the
faster you walk the longer you live
actually the longer your strides are huh
yeah is that just saying taller people
lives luck
I'm not I'm not sure no it's
proportionate to the height okay in
proportion to the high proportion to the
height yeah uh-huh
so I guess loose hip flexors probably
yeah taking bigger strides you breathe
deeper probably sleep better higher
heart rate and work cardio work while
you're walking yeah yeah makes sense
yeah New Yorkers live longer than the
average us right mhm they walk alone and
walk a lot yeah yeah but yeah so we got
those two thermistors or temperature
sensors and two LEDs that one detector
and then an accelerometer and gyro right
now we're just doing this little space
all in that little space and it's
lasting six nights or seven days without
charging without charging how did you
squeeze it all in here and then it last
seven days huge confession we have an
amazingly talented team here contingent
so good our team is some like amazing
yeah they're just you know great signal
processing we were really really lucky
to have an awesome team there's creative
hardware engineers in the Nordics yeah
so you know if you think about Nokia
right at one point was the largest phone
company in the world you know out of
Finland right
think about Ericsson you know the number
one producer of sort of cell phone tower
equipment again a lot of cell you know a
lot of signal processing so a ton of
hardware expertise in the Nordics as
well and I think people often overlook
that mmm-hmm
now you listed the sensors then you
started you start telling us like okay
there's a with the thermistors that a
monitoring temperature and there's
making recommendations give us these
kind of like recommendations that you're
giving like giving my heater
my heats going up yeah and then you're
like yo yo you might be getting so I
want to take it easy yeah actually we
had a cool let's get into the app
screenshots so I think Ronnie's gonna
come in hot with one of the nice way
go alright so here's this is mine from
this morning we started this around
11:20 but you know today my message was
challenge myself and if you click Next
on the next picture so it says here am I
ready to squirt your low resting heart
rate indicates you're well-rested and
here's a resting heart rate curve for
the last few days so you can see I was
sort of averaging 50 and today last
night I hit 46 Wow
so I was pretty I'm pretty well rested
and then we'll give you if you click on
this screen in the app if you go to the
next the next picture you'll be able to
see some more of the data so this is my
heart rate data and my readiness score
you know my average my minimum and if
you go to the next slide or next picture
sorry if here's an example of HRV so you
can see my HRV this is for a period week
is really high so that also means I'm
ready to train and will give you
information on all of it and then if you
go to one more well you know this is
also a view of sort of my deep sleep so
I got a ton of deep sleep last night two
hours crushed it and you know a
combination of all these things will
give us that score in the beginning of
the day that you saw okay so let's go
okay so a combination of all these
measurements is giving you the big score
so let's let's go back to the first one
yep and then well what we'll go back
through the challenger's out so now
let's what we'll slow it down a bit
sure so okay so your readiness score
this is your overall what you see at the
top there's an overall out of a hundred
out of honor and that means my how well
I've been resting sure
so readiness is actually this concept
we've created that gives sort of a
longer-term view of sort of how your
body is recovering and dealing with
stress so it takes into account sort of
how you slept last night but then also
how you've been sleeping the last two
weeks
your general activity load in the last
two weeks as well meaning we have
different you'll see like if you go into
I don't know if we have a screen shot
but if you go through some of the images
wrong
keep going keep going keep going keep
going
one more we took it one more I think
that was it okay I didn't include it
here but we'll give you these different
bars like this is just my sleep score
now am i reading the score so this will
show you a bar show you how full it is
right readiness the idea is it tries to
take a longer-term average one night of
sleep you can sort of power through it
yeah but it's that sort of cumulative
sleep over a few days that really wears
on you which is why sometimes you sleep
for 12 hours total yeah happens what we
try to do is we'll give you that
cumulative view of your sleep in that
cumulative view of your activity and
that readiness score and then we sort of
based on that that's that actually ends
up being from how you feel right it's
not just one night you can get through
that right but a cumulative you know
three or four good nights you're ready
to go or vice versa I came with a few
bad night's doesn't mean you know that
that incremental night even if it's okay
you still might be feeling any better
this might be like 50 or something yes
so so here there's a couple things that
are interesting
I like the tranquility yeah that's
really interesting so as I wear this
through the night how do you sense
whether or not I'm actually doing a wake
up versus a movement yeah yeah that's a
good question
so we you know we use a combination of
all those sensors so movement along with
temperature and your heart rate to
determine sort of are you awake or are
you sleeping we actually got our sleep
staging and our you know done by SSRI of
Stanford Research Institute sales
published last year and then you know
the end of last year so we'll be doing
another one for the Gentoo rank but
we're very very accurate detecting sleep
or awake and you know we there's more
bars here I wish we could scroll through
the app live but you know there's a
bunch more on the website we'll include
them in the show notes but we use a
combination of all this data to figure
out if you're sleeping how how good was
your quality of sleep you know I
remember last night my dog woke me up
twice and that the other time I woke up
actors because there was a mosquito in
the room and then it's cool to look at
the data and be like oh wow I caught
that parrot
yeah it caught that period when I woke
up and you know that mosquito was
actually bothering the heck out of me I
was trying to swat in the middle of the
night yeah yeah it's so that could have
to do with your heart rate increasing
because you have woken up [ __ ] well and
your movement your heart rate your
movement and your temperature
temperature increases as well no no no
you you're so when you're sleeping your
body tries to cool itself so your
temperature typically your core
temperature will drop right and when you
wake it's sort of the inverse inverse
right yeah so okay so there's great so
you have tranquility a total sleep time
which is just in general this notion
that we don't have a log of our sleep
and nobody wants to wake up and be like
oh I slept and you have to go and
physically write it down and digitally
log it yourself every time since it
being logged for you and then you can
look back at your past two weeks and you
can be like wow I need to cancel my
meetings tomorrow I need to actually
sleep in the morning
totally so you can you can get a better
picture of your sleep yeah and how then
it's also affecting how you feel the
next day you can assert seeing some I
feel yeah I think what we try to do is
distill it down to simple messages yep
so you saw that first message in the
absence core yeah the readiness score is
like all right push yourself I'm feeling
good today maybe it's just we were
excited about this podcast or this you
know video cast now you know as excited
to tape it but I'm ready today my broke
my heart rates down I've been eating
well the last few days you can tell my
sleep I've been getting good sleep the
last few days so I'm ready to crush it
yeah today I'm ready to give it you know
and I want to hit it hard if I go to the
gym or honestly just have a full day
packed meetings or do a bunch of work
today is a good day for me to be
productive and so we try to distill all
this data right down to some simple
messages and try giving you guidance in
the app on what you should and shouldn't
be doing yep so I mean you and I our
data you know we're like oh exactly how
does it know I'm exactly awake wait at
what part and the temperature gave you
that right but you know the average user
they just want to be able you know
understand some of this data and a light
way relatable message relatable and
corporate in their daily life now all
right let's go
all the way back let's go back to the
readiness score again yep and I can bust
out the phone if it's helpful or I don't
know if it is to show more wall stuff in
the app maybe okay okay so once we once
we go to the readiness score back to the
first slide so here we have you know
you're getting told to challenge
yourself you're seeing it kind of like
today yep go back to yesterday and stuff
so now let's go to the next one run so
here we also give you an activity target
for the day so I know you can't see it
guy [ __ ] off here but it says you can
reach your goal by walking you know five
point five miles cool for your activity
defer your activity target and this will
change based off your readiness score so
today I'm pretty well rested my goal is
a lot higher you know almost six miles
or 550 calories right a day that I had
poor readiness that goal would change
right because we want we want to sort of
you know balance the the idea of sort of
recovery and load and so the days that
you're really well recovered you should
be training hard I mean that's how pro
athletes train ride and is that they're
not recovered like post game day right
post Sunday for NFL players you're
really not doing much on Monday right
cuz they're still in a world of pain
yeah so we tried to do that as well just
by changing even for now your step goals
right yeah
is there a benefit of measurement of
resting heart rate as you sleep because
if I'm at yeah if I'm at like 45 and if
I'm at 60 is that meaning I'm very much
more anxious or less healthy or rested
yeah I'm 60 because that's what these
measurements are these are the resting
these are the resting heart rate these
are just some other data points we start
we recapturing the day and just show you
what your resting heart rate is we've
done some really good information in the
app and on our blog post on how your
resting heart rate curve should look so
Ronnie if you can go forward a few
images all tell you where to stop stop
right there Oh back one so you can see
here my resting heart rate occurred
later in the night that 46 was sort of
towards the end of the night
if it was towards even earlier in the
night it would actually mean I'm more
well rested you want to drop quickly
into your lowest rate correct if you if
you're doing that that means you're very
well you know you're really ready to
train yeah
or for some type of you know stress
mental stress even the next day that's
interesting because a lot of the
meditators of the world have very low
heart rate okay very ready for life so
we I mean that makes sense right between
but we actually show three different
images that most of our heart rate
patterns tend to sort of gravitate
towards and we give that information
actually in our blog post and we can
link to it sort of how to look at your
curve your resting heart rate curve and
how to interpret it to determine if
you're stressed or not but again we try
making some judgment calls cuz my
average was lower 52 52 was lower than
my average you know for the last few
days right and then my lowest resting
one is also lower and you know now it
would have been even better had it
occurred earlier in the night yeah but
you know that wasn't the case but I'm
still ready to train today for example
we're ready to have a lot not not
actually working out today I have a
bunch of back-to-back meetings but again
we try to interpret all this data for
users and we break it down in our app
and on our website to make it easy to
understand and it's beautiful it is it's
really well designed you make it and
easier to understand for people that
want to jump in and understand all the
more of the nuance here you have heart
rate variability
yeah I'm HRV so let's let's break that
down quick so far so heart rate you know
how many times my heart's beating per
minute cheri variability the time
between beats yeah okay so what's the
significance yeah actually if we can go
to the next picture so this is my weekly
view of my HRV and we give a pretty good
example here but it's exactly what you
said the time interval between
heartbeats Susan is relaxed a healthy
hearts beating heart beating rate shows
variation correct so when they're so the
more variation the more healthy you are
yeah exactly so it's sort of
counterintuitive because because then
when it's when your hearts beating like
consistent it's because you're maybe
like stress and you need to like sort
your environment for predatory things
maybe like that's your autonomic nervous
system or your flight or flight right
that that system that controls that you
know one of the things we that people
have been looking at as a measure of
stress or you know whether you're in
sort of sympathetic or parasympathetic
and sympathetic would be that example
like an animals coming there's a line
that's jumping in the room and me and
you are like damn how are we gonna get
out of here yeah right
yeah I just push you in to do that I
would try to kick in space I grab one of
these you know mics and throw it but um
heart rate variability is exactly you
know as far as the nuance is it is a
space between each heartbeat you want
variation to higher the variation
generally the more relaxed or you know
or you know you are versus device you
know you sort of set it when when you're
really tense and stressed you can almost
feel your heart beating right it's that
like constant right it's like you're
stressed you're not I almost like to
think about it like a car like you're
driving a stick shift car and you're
just like sitting there revving engine
cruising ready like you know ready to
stoplight like you have that variation
ready to hit it right versus if your
engine was all the way arrived up all
the time right you might not be able to
go right when you need to yep so it's
it's that concept of stress and it's
been linked to actually you know HRV has
been used for you know plenty of
clinical areas but a lot of it has been
you know HIV being a good indicator of
heart attack and stroke cardiac stress
actually even for stone for PTSD some
for you know some therapy related work
in there has been shown that by looking
at HOV you can see when they're actually
overcoming or when they're having bad
you know sort of bouts of PTSD as well
so there's been a whole ton of you know
new work that's been going on and heart
rate variability is this sort of new way
to look at our heart rate data that's
tied to our nervous system all men HIV
such an interesting measure
okay now what does anywhere below 20
over 100 mean so below 20 is not as
healthy then and over 100 on is a sure
so we don't try to call in its
milliseconds as its milliseconds oh so
okay so then we're following a mil per
milliseconds you know a variation very
correct yeah it actually is so that the
time unit we give is called RM SSD since
the root means squared of successive
differences between two you know a few
beats right between a few beats well
yeah technically every single beat yeah
yeah right and then you you average it
over a certain time period you want to
take two hov over one minute over five
minutes over you know
the whole night yeah so what we do is we
measure it every five minutes and give
it an average so we do these five minute
average blocks but we measure every
single beat yeah but yeah so it's a
millisecond unit we don't you know we we
don't want to say that sort of 20 under
20 is unhealthy you know but we what we
want people to sort of realize is
whether they're stressed or not stressed
and realize that things that improve so
for me actually like when I go do some
cardio activity if it's like cardio
activity my HRV improves or if I go have
a heavy workout I'll sort of improve two
days after because I need a day to
recover if I go drink a bunch of alcohol
and eat a late meal on an e-2 Karrueche
Berkowitz and fries my HOV will get
smoked it'll be down at time yeah and so
you can start to see sort of how your
lifestyle choices are affecting that HIV
or stress metric damn yeah you said you
can start measuring your eating habits
how they affect you yeah how your drug
habits affect totally yeah um how your
stress habits affect you
yeah I mean wow this is and then you get
a visual representation of it in a
scientific objective form that's exactly
which then further ties you closer to
your own body
yeah I mean your own habits and your own
actions yeah hell yeah I mean here's an
example I used to drink to keep tequila
was like my drink of choice
tequila on the rocks right and I was
seeing my best friend we hadn't caught
up in like a year and I you know sat
down with him and I had like a steak
dinner and two just two glasses tequila
nice to Keela on the rocks with the line
but man my HRV was smoked I slept like
crap you know a resting heart rate was a
ton higher I started to realize that man
I having heavy like a hard liquor like
that that late in the night right before
I go to bed and a fat Stan if that steak
definitely didn't do well for me roast
is now when I do have a drink when I
meet up with friends like I'll try to
have something earlier iced tend to stay
away now from sort of the hard spirits
I'll just have a beer with a buddy you
know at 4 or 5 p.m. right and that way
my body actually digests at all I go to
bed and I still get great sleep yeah
recovered huge difference between a beer
at five or six verse' beer at 1 or 2
a.m.
yes yeah huge difference in most most
most of the time we're not we're kind of
chasing after a feeling the feeling of
being more intoxicated the feeling of
being more loose which is why don't take
that last one at then then it's
interesting once you get all these
biometrics back yeah you continue to how
do you how do your habits change so for
me it changed dramatically I started
realizing you know once I saw that data
oh man that that extra drink is really a
bad choice right or another one I
realized was just dude why not eat
dinner
I wouldn't you eat yeah I was doing
intermittent fasting I used to eat
really late and sort of realize that
that was affecting my sleep yep and so I
moved my intermittent fasting window way
earlier finishing dinner at 6:00 p.m.
and you know then when I go to sleep now
my HRV is better my resting heart rates
lower I wake up feeling better the next
day right and that's what I was doing
intermittent fasting in the first place
for to feel better right to lose weight
feel better you know have more energy
and turns out actually that way wasn't
optimized for me so you can see what
works for you and then you make that
lifestyle change I think you know for me
it's always hard you have so much going
on in your life you're distracted by
your cell phone you know you got five
meetings back to back the next day you
don't really have time to ask yourself
anymore how you feel feel all right and
it's totally true right we wake up we're
broader by messages right
but I think what's really cool is if you
wake up and check some of this data
that's objective you can start to better
understand actually oh yeah how do I
feel you know brings you back into your
body a bit yep
oh man that was a good explanation of
Hari variability hell yeah
okay and then let's go on to the next
one Ron and so now deep sleep okay so
what's the difference between sleep and
deep sleep so look I'm gonna borrow one
from Matt Walker here all stages of
sleep are important yes
they all have their vital functions deep
sleep I think is probably a more
interest to some of the guys in the room
just because your testosterone release
majority that happens during deep sleep
a lot of the physical muscular repair
happens during deep and so you know in
that sense like yeah you know deep sleep
is pretty important and a lot of
authority virtue yeah any of the muscle
growth in repair so we give you that
description right there and yet see I I
did really well last night I had you
know two and a half two and a half or
two hours and five minutes which is
awesome how do you know that it's deep
sleep versus is it so we have you know
some algorithm you know development that
we've done looking at that heart rate
data in combination with that
temperature data movement and
respiration rate which we also capture
do to figure out what stage you're in
and we've got it validated where the
third party SSRI Stanford Research
Institute as well yeah so we've done a
pretty extensive you know analysis of
that policy before launching our product
and do you want more do you want to be
closer to 35% of your total sleep time
being deep sleep you know so it's gonna
vary depending at what stage you are in
your life so young people have more
detail people have more deep sleep yeah
we I mean I've seen some younger sort of
21 year old college athletes that have
like two to two-and-a-half hours every
night you know they're in the top 1% of
our data yeah I think the average in our
you you know that we've seen on average
is a little bit below an hour which is
about what it is you know when you look
at some of the medical literature but
you'll see actually as you age
you know get you know a little bit worse
and worse you know one of the things
that they find out they found out you
know in terms of sleep science this is
published last year I forget which
journal I think it was sell but they
found out actually also within deep
sleep is when this plaque is removed
from your brain it's called beta-amyloid
and the same plaque actually they found
out is you know they think is linked to
Alzheimer's because people have
Alzheimer's tend to have high amounts of
beta amyloid and yet we found that deep
sleep it's actually this process when
the you know the brain is getting rid of
some of that plaque now all stages of
sleep are important and so but I think
you know for a lot of people who are
focused on an area that they're lacking
and it tends to be deep sleep and then
do you make a recommendation on how to
get more deep sleep or was that
something like we were talking about
earlier with drinking later eating late
might influence totally so no we right
now we give light recommendations right
so we'll try giving you sort of an
optimal bedtime window because timing
again is a lot of it yep going to bed at
the right time is gonna help you
actually get better deep sleep believe
it or not yeah and then same thing you
know now what does it come to the timing
of those lifestyle choices whether it's
eating what it's working out and we we
are starting to actually compile what we
call notes and tags I didn't show any
screenshots yet because we're still
working on it you met demo but the idea
is for people to actually be able to
quickly you know either us automatically
detect or you may only input something
you did and then tie that back to your
sleep you know I think what's
interesting is we spend a third of our
lives sleeping right and we really don't
we all sort of take that for the most
part for granted and if I told you Alan
hey there's a pill you can tear any
years of life thirty years of life so
yeah right but what happens during those
thirty years right
we you know normally consider it like
boring nothing's happening but a ton of
stuff is happening right your muscle
repair is happening your cognitive
repair is happening right you're home
hormone released for your optimal like
even like just emotional balance is
happening right you're these plaques
being removed from your brain is
happening I mean if I told you you can
take a pill and this pill is
make you lose weight you know actually
lower your blood pressure
gonna make you think better clear the
next day I have higher testosterone
right improve your memory how many of us
would take that pill yeah everyone right
but we sort of choose not to whether
knowingly and unknowingly and that's
sleep
yeah and that pill is sleep right not
take that pill every day or not take as
much of that pill as we can so I think
if we help people sort of understand
this one-third of our life that we
consider dull and realize that actually
this is one of the most vital parts of
our you know of our like human lives
yeah and it affects the other two-thirds
of our lives we think everyone's gonna
be much happier better performing better
whatever is important for that so I
think that's what we're trying to do at
aura we're trying to show people sort of
how these choices right that you make in
your lives that seem innocuous have a
huge impact on your sleep these
relatable ways of understanding both
sleep are a re variability how to live
healthier and having this readiness
score every seventh day being able to
break it down into the nuances well if
you want having it be so discreet you
know you can't even tell you can't even
feel like you read don't even feel like
I'm wearing it totally and it's just
gonna get smaller and it's just gonna
get even more a smaller better more
accurate a longer battery life so and
yeah seven days is really good battery
life okay that's right there's our timer
those really good timing with Ron and I
I was literally saying let's run you
through our last questions at the end of
the show now so our pre we talked about
this a lot we asked people what they
think about wealth inequality and
globalization or drowning
and I guess means in extremes right I
think you know the average you know has
probably gone up right in the world in
terms of like you know wealth in certain
countries but these streams are probably
even more desperate than before so you
know I think the low end and the high
end has totally gotten pulled apart you
know I think it's it's a huge issue for
our society today you know I think in
terms of one of the ways we try to think
about it though is sort of your health
is you know another part of your wealth
right how you feel every day sort of no
amount of money can necessarily buy that
so for us you know being able to help
people improve their health you know
it's gonna improve how you feel the next
day whether you're a millionaire a
billionaire or just you know a guy who's
in college or a girl who's in college
right trying to do better on your next
test so I think it's a huge important
topic and there's definitely extremes
that are happening but I guess what
we're trying to do is contribute what we
can to the health side of it which which
I'd actually call an important part of
your wealth yeah that's a really good
one that's a good way to look at it if
you can help make your health augment
your health it will make you feel really
good throughout your life yeah that's
good so okay now what do you think's the
most beautiful thing in the world the
most beautiful thing in the world man I
don't see it right now cuz I'm already
getting excited for it the fall the fall
of college football season I just think
it's an awesome time of the year
everyone going back to school I'm a huge
college football fan I went to Michigan
and it's sort of that time to everyone
gets together to cheer you know cheer
for sort of a common cause yeah and it's
just it's fun it's fun being around
friends and fun getting out there yeah
yeah and the fall weather is just
something awesome so yeah yeah
there's something my girlfriend's gonna
like hate me she's like college there's
just something about 50,000 people that
are all attending an event and rooting
for a cause
yeah and that's why we want to fill
sports stadiums for curious
intellectuals yes to learn that full day
events because we know the feeling of
50,000 people because we ourselves
understand the sports as well we've been
to all these different sports events and
and felt that energy and so to be able
to replicate that for curious
intellectual it's obviously not the most
beautiful thing in the world I mean
there's clearly a ton of more beautiful
things out there but there was something
magical about that moment yeah something
magical about those moments yet do you
think we're alone in the cosmos my
personal view is now I think the world
is just too complex and there's you know
the human life wasn't just an accident
right like it's there's so many there's
got to be in my view if we exist here
there's got to be types of other life
that exists in so many different
far-reaching places that you know I
haven't even fathom so III for me would
be sort of the little that I do know
about life sort of incomprehensible to
think that there is an other forms in
other places yeah in the
multidimensionality of things
yeah all right and do you think there's
a designer to the universe
and it's a complex question I think you
know we I do think we all art designers
I do think we have little little choices
that we get to make every day that have
an impact and we do have an impact on
each other you know how we started this
you know videocast and you know how what
are we chose to have a good interaction
or bad interaction some of that was up
to us so I do think we are designers in
our own right that effect each other but
is there like a master designer that's
helping harmonize or dis harmonize like
every different person I I think so
not sure but I believe so it's again
like one of these things that just seems
like almost too good to be true
who do you think would win in the scrap
between you and the master designer come
on give yourself a little more credit Oh
a kick its ass dirty rat you don't
realize that you're actually fighting
yourself yeah what about you what do you
think a lot of variables a lot of
variables a lot of variable a lot of
variables but it's an exciting thought
experiment it expands the consciousness
to new areas of thought that yeah
typically don't get a lot of acting we
typically don't go there that much so
totally now I tend to think that we as
species tend to get very focused on one
variable or two you know we were talking
about the sensors in that ring yeah that
is one small small small variable yep
right there's so many other variables
out there right and but yet we want to
get really good at that one thing you
know us as a company yeah we want to get
really really damn good at getting your
sleep staging getting your heart rate
variability as accurate as well that's
like a very one small very so so take
into account how ridiculous this would
sound you have you have to infrared
young lights you have an infrared light
sensor then you have an accelerometer a
gyroscope
now think about how you know you're
crunching all of those variables to
provide horror a higher variability and
sleep data because you have to crunch
all this data to make the best sense of
it right now this exact same analogy
applies to the way we function
politically in sociological because if
you only take one variable into account
about immigration or health care or
abortion or whatever the social issue is
all of a sudden you'll catch yourself
not crunching enough data yep to have
the most valuable sort of takeaway and
an opinion on the issue at hand totally
yeah I mean frankly we even think about
that to some degree when we're designing
a product right like for some people we
may be able to isolate oh yeah it was
that drink you had it - ambos oh right
that caused your heart rate to Jack and
truly you're not to get good sleep but
there's other people that you know as
people work more than one dimension or
more than one action and so there's a
cumulative amount of actions and
emotions that we have that affect how we
feel and how we recover so it's it's
something that we're trying to actually
do a better job of from a product
perspective but it's it you know I think
there's a quote from Stewart Butterfield
it's like you know basically good
product designers unless you have
empathy for your users yeah it's like
hard to be good at this yeah I don't
know what the exact quote is right but
um I think it's a really good point is
that we we have to take into account all
those dimensions like you asked is HRV
below 20 bad well you know for a certain
amount of our users right add a brill
have HRV below 20 and they may have some
type of emotional stress that they're
dealing with right they may have some
they may have PTSD
right they may have Lyme disease right
and so it doesn't necessarily mean that
they can't still get value out of this
tool you know but we're trying to make a
product you know longer-term that can
help people in those different
dimensions sort of regardless of where
they are yeah you you made an
interesting point there as well about
isolation of the the potential
you're isolating what it could be that
is the cause of what the variables that
you're measuring RS and it you're you're
saying that it could be the tequila or
it could have been something else about
the person's health from the past I'm
that it's affecting the way that their
heart rate variability is functioning
right now whatever it may be
yeah and so because you're doing that
you're getting a better understanding of
them they're getting a better
understanding of themselves right I'm
the data you have more data to play with
over a longer period of time yeah yeah
this is this is very interesting
technology and it's very important for
humanity be able to measure biometrics
yeah about ourselves and understand how
they can be made relatable to us totally
yeah so it's a little bit of putting
health back into consumers you know yeah
you know I think a lot of it is today in
today's society like we normally wait to
go see a doctor until we're sick well
you know if I was able to show you that
hey every night you have that late drink
or late meal that that's affecting your
deep sleep right and let's say less deep
sleep we know now there's a positive
correlation with the development of
Alzheimer's you maybe understand it our
users understand that these deep sleep
acts that might work for them can help
them sort of be preventative right
reactive right because then it's too
late
preventative health care and this is you
know this is really diagnosing you know
digitally yeah yeah and and preventing
the onset of disease ahead of time
because you are realizing that I'm not
getting enough deep sleep sorry
variability oh yeah and that's that's
super important and look at how you've
packaged it up really really smart team
that's been able to put this together
really great work you guys yeah it's
very impressive everyone definitely
check out worrying or in calm also
there's a discount code in the bio
I'm just gonna quote simulation 50 bucks
50 bucks offer two bucks off your or
ring and it's $2.99 right now $2.99 at
399 $2.99 to 399 right now
you know matte black or the stealth as
we call it and the rose gold are a
little bit more expensive of a finish of
the fish but this totally worth getting
a better understanding of what's going
on with your health a bigger picture of
it
and also taking care of yourself by
analyzing that data to get these
recommendations from ordering which are
amazing
Harpreet exceptional work I am super
grateful to have had you on the show and
teach us about this now like what it's
pleasure to learn from you and just be
part of it
thanks for man we're gonna we're gonna
be doing a good amount of testing with
this ourselves soon simulation will also
be you know running tests and you know
providing feedback to people and also
I'm letting people know how it's going
with us and then and then also you know
recommending more people to join us in
the movement to inspire more people
thinkers and doers into our world to
build the future
awesome awesome episode thanks everyone
for tuning in if you guys had a good
time definitely give us a comment below
let us know your thoughts we want to be
engaging with you in this community also
definitely don't just consume this
content go and create with it go make
something with it write a post make a
video maybe go and explore sleep in more
detail yourself explore heart rate
variability maybe start a company in it
get excited about it
also subscribe join the family
join us on patreon you to continue
sustaining this and growing it to join
us there thanks Ron are producing
partner thinks everyone thanks Ron yeah
much love peace
you